when we think about Isis now I think
it's important to try to understand what
they are and why they're being as
effective as they are first they
shouldn't be as effective as they are
they've got a doctrine that most people
particularly in the Muslim world don't
buy into their behavior is absolutely
abhorrent and they don't offer a clear
road to a better future it is a road in
the minds of many people back to the
seventh century and that's not somewhere
a lot of people want to go so why are
they effective the first is to
understand they're effective in a very
unique environment right now the Middle
East and North Africa are in disarray
many of the traditional structures that
have held things together there have
collapsed they're in an environment that
I liken to a patient that has HIV AIDS
hiv/aids does not kill a patient what it
does is it weakens the immune system
until a very weak disease that normally
would be pushed off easily becomes
potentially life-threatening and that's
that region right now and so a disease
like Isis which otherwise would be
laughable in certain times is not the
second reason Isis is effective is if
they were a traditional terrorist
organization or a traditional insurgent
movement they would have certain
strengths and weaknesses but they would
be largely geographically contained by
the fact you'd be affected by what they
see and do sort of as far as you can see
or as close as your cousin is and he
drove over and told you about it and
that would be for most of history that's
how these kinds of organizations were
largely contained in certain areas if
they did is spread they spread very
slowly because they spread by word of
mouth or mailing or newspapers and
whatnot Isis however has hit the
intersection of modern technology
information technology so now we get up
in the morning and we think Isis is in
Texas we think Isis is in Nigeria we
think Isis is under our bed we think
that they are constantly killing people
and that they have created this sense
that they are this growing movement that
is about to take over not just their
part of the Middle East but the world
also it creates this sense among many
particularly frustrated young people
around the world okay here's the new new
thing there a little bit disgusting in
the way they act but they're pretty
strict they are sort of Peck's bad boy
and why you don't like them there's
something seductive about the idea of
tough guys who are willing to do
anything and stick it to the man we got
to understand that an awful lot of
people ran off and joined the circus in
one age or they ran off and joined gangs
so they ran off and did things that
later in life didn't seem very smart but
there was this seductive idea of
adventure and so those things wrapped
together and suddenly give it this power
it should not have I think what we need
to understand is because it's this loose
set of franchises and it's not an
organization that just is headquartered
in Raqqa in Syria and therefore limited
by the the things they can see in touch
in fact they've created the idea that
it's an idea and it's an idea that is
customized in each area people take that
they used to take al-qaeda now they take
Isis and they Boko Haram stamps
themselves we're Isis now and they may
not do anything directly with anyone in
Syria or any of the former al Qaeda
leadership but now they've adopted the
t-shirt and the brand and it gives this
sense that they have a new level of
credibility and so it becomes very very
important that we understand that aspect
of it
Isis is a military problem only in its
smallest sense it's a geographic
diplomatic and social problem in its
broadest sense and then it is a
communication problem and it's very core